[Music]
everyone knows the story right it's 2:00
a.m. the pager goes off and you have to
figure out what went wrong
right how do you get back to having
happy customers and more importantly how
do you get back to sleep right and I'm
sure most people some people in here
I've I definitely gone through that
experience right it's a little bit about
myself my name is andre kelly and on the
product manager for stackdriver into the
response and management sure they call
this IRM and today we're gonna talk
about a kind of new frontier I call it
in the space of internet response right
what I refer to as data management and
the objective is how can we use it to
get more sleep and so we'll discuss
today the technology that DCP is has
developed or has started and is
developing that kind of enables just
technology and disability all right and
really work towards the vision of fewer
shorter and smaller outages that's what
we're working towards so just a quick
rundown on what we're gonna go through
just the lifecycle overall but incident
kind of calibrate everyone process
management is kind of a interesting
component to this so we're gonna go over
that kind of real quickly high-level and
then we're gonna dive a little deeper
into the data management as I see it in
the future of it what we can do there or
the benefits arm and then get to the fun
stuff we're gonna demo IRM and look at
some of the data management
functionality we have in IRM today and
then we're gonna wrap up time willing
we're gonna take some questions so I
want to keep it interactive so let's get
started so lifecycle so I think it's
very important to highlight this that
incidents are inevitable all right like
we're all gonna have them the matter
amount of auto healing and anything that
we put together it's it's bound to
happen and I think it's important to
kind of appreciate that and recognize
that because I nabel's us to then
planned for that case all right what can
we do what things are in place what
processes do we have to put in place to
make sure we can respond appropriately
and that's a key part how we did enjoy
management at Google
so just a quick rundown of kind of a
very simplified admittedly view of an
internet lifecycle right kinda weird
things start and where things end up
usually this is a root cause event right
and usually it's like high percentages
seventy percent or something if these
are based on change changing code
changing config some other activity
causing a problem that leads to some
kind of detection so either a human
detects it or your cloud support your
support team tells you or an automated
detection system detects it but then
soon after some human hopefully is aware
of the problem and that starts the
response so usually some initial
diagnosis as to how bad the problem is
is what's going on and then the meat of
the activity happens in this latest
investigation and what typically goes on
there is that you're gathering data and
the human is doing some kind of
correlation process to figure out what's
wrong
she can figure out the best action to
mitigate after some stunts a successful
mitigation we then can sometimes fork
into how do we capture lessons learned
and very traditional process our bigger
cases is from like a post-mortem in some
cases it could be smaller and I'll go
through some of those more lightweight
processes how that can be helpful of
capturing lessons learned and then there
was the resolve state that we call it
it's really about kind of fixing that
bug all right so we mitigated the
problem that doesn't mean we actually
fix the bug right that could be
something as quick as a rollback but
then the actual bug fix could take days
it could take in involvement several
teams so you want to make that a
different stage but that's really kind
of outside the scope of what I
considered the the tooling that we're
going to talk about today in instant
response IRM doesn't want to be a tool
that is doing code changes and config
changes and so on right so we're putting
that we recognize it as part of the
lifecycle but we don't want to be
involved in actual directly that
activity and that's why that's a little
bit
different in color but it's key to
recognize that we don't consider it
instant and done until all those stages
are complete right and and that
connection of that lifecycle is key and
you can extract a lot of interesting
elements and data from that to help
future things and that's one of the key
parts of the data management idea so
just thinking a little further so just
to cover some more elements here so we I
typically break down into the lifecycle
into three major pillars all right one
is people management and this I think
many are probably familiar with this is
the on-call rotation kind of setup right
the schedule how do you get the right
alert to the right person this part of
the people are getting that first kind
of notification to the human that
component right that's what this covers
here now we are not doing this because
there's a lot of sorry it may be phrased
in it we're not directly invested in
this right now because there was a lot
of a great existing tools in the
marketplace to cover that however we're
Google kind of has a lot of expertise
from our various years in instant
response is in process management right
kind of efficient ways to coordinating a
command an incident and make sure
there's no gaps or overlaps in the
response and this emerge from the
emergency response system that came out
in the 70s from firefighting
that happened in here in California and
so we adapted that for the kind of
incident for the kind of IT space
usually in kind of the similar structure
premier pyramid of roles and
responsibilities and we're going with it
a little bit and how that kind of fits
into the tooling and the last place in
that is that the new item and I see and
this is the data management and this is
kind of elaborate more what I mean by
that right in today's system specially
looking the stack driver and GCP there's
a wealth of data available we have
metrics we have logs we have traces we
have profile information there's a
wealth of data available the user can
when an alert fires possibly can look at
so the question is how can the system
itself help you manage that data so you
can kind of max
mais your exploration investigation how
can we leapfrog you if there's a path of
investigation how can we leap frogging
data points down that investigation we
mentioned can earlier that investigation
period is about gathering data and doing
that correlation so how can we do some
correlation for you and then jump you
along that path and you're gonna do as a
human and leave the tupper the tougher
kind of analysis that humans do so well
that community kind of struggle that for
you right and that's one of the key
elements of it and then data in other
senses as well right so the data in
terms of like when you first land or
first start to respond how do we make it
so that you're we maximize or your
situational awareness so you become
aware what's the problem is what's a
blast radius and so on and then how do
we manage that data that's what you
tracked as your response over time so
you can make me more efficient in the
future so all these pieces of data can
Astra be talking about like existing ops
data information about the system of GCP
and data that you're added into the
system is he made his a human curating
that data as important so this is a
quick back of course I can talk about
kind of the process management element
it's important to kind of review you
kind of what Google's view this is and
then how data management slots into that
all right so first it's into the
management at Google you might hear this
call I'm AG it's mentioned in the 2's
are ebooks and it's really kind of the
protocol we use inside Google for
Incident Response now a quick mention
about IRM IRM is internally the
next-generation internet response tool
for Google to use in its response system
right so replacing about at least three
tools and a couple of hanger off tools
as well consolidating that into one tool
we're providing that same tooling
externally through stackdriver as IRM as
is and we'll I want to get to the
Democrats all the exciting stuff right
but what that tool then provides is
years of battle-tested processes that
cover three main things and this is the
process part so one go to the idea of
coordination right the
you need to be able to recognize roles
and sorry yeah so rules and
responsibilities so that idea I
mentioned several times of kind of we
don't want gaps or overlaps and effort
the SRA books the workbook especially
talks about the idea of if someone is
responding to an incident and someone
else in you know with all good
intentions says oh I can help and they
jump in and they start doing something
but the other person has no idea what's
going on that could actually make things
worse right so you need to establish the
idea in practice that as a team we're
gonna respond to incidents this way
we're gonna know who's gonna do what and
we know who is in charge in terms of
their typically call the incident
commander right so it's important to
have these processes in place and this
is goes back to the idea of saying an
incident it's gonna happen even if you
typically don't have a long history of
them you gotta have a process in place
but when it does your could get back to
happy customers and back to sleep
possibly I'm really into sleep you can
tell okay second part is communication
and just from life you know
communication is super important but in
incident management it goes to that same
thing in that case I'm scenario of
someone was responding and that good
intention colleague wants to jump in
they could jump in that needs to
communicate with someone they know that
they should know to go to the internet
commander and said hey I can help out I
know this system right and they take him
again to the role to help out so it's
about communication right and it's
several levels of communication so one
within the team right and lowest level
of the response who's doing what in the
response and then you need to
communicate kind of outside the team
kind of within your organization right
so many times VP's want to know when
something kind of public is going on if
your thing is on Twitter with some bad
feedback some VP start going hey man
what's going on with that uh this issue
that I'm seeing and so you want to keep
them in inform but not just inform when
they ping you proactively you don't want
them on your back as you're trying to
respond to the incident and so part of
the iMac system is actually sharding up
their role in activities of who's
responding to the problem and who's
actually communicating all right and
then who's actually commanding as well
and so you can start to see kind of
a separation of responsibilities and how
they all work together in concert and in
the third level if the Internet intents
needed is a kind of communicating
outside the organization right through
your support channels or through Twitter
or through your status dashboard tell
your customers what's going on because
otherwise they get this and seeing you
you Road that that well built a goodwill
and Trust this is all part of that idea
and lastly the idea of control right
kind of the sense that you have to keep
up with what's going on and be mindful
the scope and impact of the incident and
so this is bigger than a lot of the role
of the incident commander right they say
hey do we need more people I have a
comedy then I gotta obviously but man
this thing is really getting out of
control do I need to get more people
involved and in in the protocol and this
works at Google but I mean we have to
you have to work with your team
interfere the works a commander could
actually a boss to become part of the
incident and the commanders then telling
their boss what to do right it's not
about kind of hierarchy it's about the
process and about working in that moment
to solve a problem right so that's the
Cobell about the idea behind control
right being mindful of that and trying
to address the problem I mentioned here
in the slide about heroics right it
shouldn't take heroics whenever an
incident comes around to make sure to
get you back to happy customers that
should be the exception this should be
orderly that you're not extending your
workday so that means they clean ships
handoff in an orderly process with that
so the commander goes you know what
command it's five o'clock I got dinner
plans with my family I need to find a
new incident commander and hand off the
process and that should be an orderly
process and that's part of it as well
that should be built into the process
okay so I wasn't sure how good this
people could see this can people the
back see this all right no no no okay
thank you for that feedback I tell you
what we'll look at one for the demo to
data management I'll switch over to
another incident that has some English
this is wealth
kind of filled out but I'll try to get
you the same kind of information but
just by regional areas right the things
that has talked about in terms of the
processes and elements are reflected
here right this incident I recreated it
from the SRB workbook I don't know if
any familiar with it but in Belgium a
couple years ago we had four lightning
strikes at a data center and some
batteries in the UPS acted funny because
of four lightning strikes right and so
some disk went weird right and some this
became not operational it required
restarting this little process - can I
get things back on line and the data
center so things were and people were
being impacted and so this is recapping
can the capturing the roles that were
involved as described in a post-mortem
kind of information that people
referenced and then who we're trying to
be kind of communicated and informed
about so in the lower right hand you see
subscriptions
that's the outbound communication to
stakeholders so they keep they're aware
of what's going on before they start
pinging you right on the left here at
the bottom is a link so these are links
to play books and what they found out
and the incident was that we have no
process hub of how to bat to restart a
bunch of VMs and this together like we
just you don't know how to do it we
didn't this is a couple before so there
was okay a process of kind of
establishing a scripts and Doc's and
trying to capture that information there
was a process they we start like I think
one or two but the scale of the problem
needed a whole different extension of
that process and so new Doc's spun up to
capture that so this is kind of a way of
tracking any information right and then
the top there is the summary capturing
the status the impact and the next
update right so if you're a stakeholder
you come by the internet in SA okay let
me see what's going on beyond what
they're saying you have a human readable
sorry I let me rephrase that
you have a in plain English readable way
a summary of the problem and not
technical jargon saying you know I'm
running this command and this is going
on but I can read that there's this this
problem going on and so on and so forth
right it's meant to be about consuming
the data and not about the details
there's a different section of the app
that's
that you also see that in the upper
right there's a sense of the severity
and also a comms room so for the low
level responders no details they're able
to actually click in and see all the
stream of data in that slack room for us
it was IRC right so it has the
mechanisms for you to kind of quickly
get more data and get a snippet of data
and move on and stricture the
information and this is about kind of
the the observer kind of view and the
incident commander view of the incident
and where they would stay and manage
information there's other sections meant
for the operators that are more detailed
at a lower level and the data management
part will go into that shows you kind of
when you get started what information is
available for you and how we structure
that to get started okay so with that
let's talk about data management then
right we talked about initially
coordinate communication and control the
three C's of the IM AG process alright
so data management with our push this
brings in kind of two more seasons and
now we're up to five seas and first in
that sorry that didn't go there okay
it's contacts right what can we do with
the data information available to us to
make sure that when you first start you
have the best context to get started in
terms of situational awareness and
continue that as you go so not just as
you start but kind of maintain that
information and the context of the
incident to everything that we do right
and then I mentioned the framework to
collect human curated data as part of
that process and then the fifth is Auto
this is a cheating by saying see here
but autocorrelation right not only are
we looking for data just to show the
user but can we correlated with other
activities in the system in the
environment and especially at DCP and
stackdriver where we're also your cloud
provider in your monitoring system if
you have the instrument response tool on
this
there's additional data that we have
that others may not have available and
over the past several years for example
Google has worked on one of our sister
teams has has worked together there in
in depth in GCB DevOps that maps and
collects relationship data between
different entities and resources
throughout environments right so we see
communication data because you can fit
changes and this data is gonna resource
the research and expanding over time and
so that gives us the raw data to
correlate and work on and identifying
failure patterns that we can raise and
highlight to the user will visualize the
technology in a demo later on but just
to highlight what that raw information
is and what we're doing and kind of the
benefit of combining that vertical
integration of cloud provider monitoring
system and Incident Response together
okay so what is this get us alright so
one I mentioned we're working for a few
outages and how does that work
right so within the end lifecycle we
want to make sure that as you're riding
bugs and putting follow-up action items
that you're able to be able to connect
it to actually what's a service that
keeps triggering these things right
what's the service that keeps putting it
false positives like what's at alert
pause I need to work on
right can we start connecting that end
symptom they can a causal structural
thing that needs attention because if
they're that that everyone I'm sure in
this room has had a case where an
incident happened when we knew we had a
follow-up bug to do that would fix that
would have just a problem but we just
didn't get to it so how can we highlight
those situations better so that the more
the riskiest items actually gets
attention for management for investment
sometimes they really are collectors
needed to solve the problem right so how
can we show over the past 30 days or
whatever or past two quarters that our
biggest outages were caused by the same
service connecting those things together
is actually the key part of that then
data management and leave to small to
fewer in outages second is idea of
shorter outages right so and this is the
kind of
the two key pillars of the idea of the
data management and IRM and that's the
idea of context and continuous learning
that through automated ways and and
through low friction ways users are able
to input data that we can then leverage
for future occurrences so that the time
to more valuable information and
understanding the current situation gets
shorter and shorter right now I'm out
there for appreciation not necessarily
this is this is exactly what would
happen but we want to make sure that
each time that you're having the same
alert fire and it's a similar situation
that it should take you less time right
a system should help you learn and then
just usually have to be the same
responder to actually benefit from the
previous time that you address this
issue then there's also kind of the case
of post mortems right so post mourners
are very common way to kind of capture
and traditionally lessons learn but I
bet if I pulled this room how many
people actually did post forums you'd be
quiet'
kind of low ratio all right it's one of
those things where it's like vegetables
right everyone knows they're good for
you but nobody actually eats them right
it or not no one eats them enough I put
it that way right and so this is my word
Rambler a joke now we're trying to be
the ranch dressing for your vegetables
right so for post modems right how did
we get you to create post modems more
post most more post mortems
but less effort how can we take that
data that you that we identified and you
curated put it together and generate the
majority of that post more time together
all right so those are the things we're
working towards and then lastly smaller
outages so this is the example of a
correlation and we'll go through a live
one and this is the example the insight
that will be due right currently need a
learning metric with a metric in your
system that's related to it and so while
correlations insights are important most
important most importantly we want to
make sure that we're focusing this
information at the stage the right stage
of the life cycle and when the incident
starts
focus there should be mitigation not
good cause analysis sometimes we must
fall into that trap of saying oh let me
go find that line of the bug that's
causing a problem when they roll back
can be faster right we want to make sure
that we're providing data that helps
information that targets you to mitigate
the problem and stop but we usually call
the trigger
so the code might be the bug but a
deployment was the trigger or the
redirection of traffic from the config
was the trigger
how do you identify those events so that
you can stop the impact to your users as
fast as possible and then later
once we've mitigated recognize that
event and then switch to information
that's more focused and helpful to do
the resolution all right
so understanding those stages and
lifecycle elements and what that flow
looks like and forging information data
focus to each of those at the time okay
so with that let's go do a demo I'm
going to do a little bit of gymnastics
here to get to the right thing but it
should be all right so before I started
the talk I did something the hips are
sharp and when I'm familiar with hips a
shop it's the most most commonly broken
app ever but we kicked off something
that caused a problem and so here in our
slack channel we now get an alert saying
something happened to have to shop so
let's take a look what would happen
terms of what you get in IRM based on
that alert so this is a live demo so a
little bit janky I haven't mentioned
stock drivers is an alpha so if you see
any bruises or short things it's cause
it's alpha but available to sign up
let's talk about afterwards so here in
terms of context like what do we provide
so we know it's still firing we have a
chart at the volumetric immediately we
see that yep it went up around the time
of the alert and just it's still up
what's going on there we can then see
that we have an insight that triggered
that when the latency 20p you shut up
for this pod contain at the same time or
right before and it's sustained like I
said it could be related right so we're
not promising that we identifying
root-cause directly we're trying to jump
you down or leapfrog you down that
investigation path that you're gonna
follow naturally anyway right so this is
key information that you can use
immediately right now there's also links
here to tools like metric Explorer and
rechak Explorer gives you a way to kind
of slice and dice data and this link is
a thing that will convey the context of
the incident
into that tool so we would preload the
metric of the correlated metric at the
time of the incident and then you can
start adjusting things so when one
useful scenario here is that if you have
a fleet of VMs or say gke clusters in
different zones and you have an alert
happening you could then use electric
Explorer to quickly slice and dice your
data to see if it's centered to one's
own or one region maybe it's one region
you can just drain it right so it's
about kind of conveying that the problem
that you're having into the tools that
you use for your ops navigation rather
than you as a human starting from
scratch each time same thing applies
here to these log links so these are
this is a link to logs that would reduce
it the time of the logs for the last 30
minutes around the time of the incident
based on the resource it is and for log
based metrics we then also apply the
query so we are filtering it down to
exactly what was related to populate and
triggering that incident for that alert
sorry
and same thing much it gets more here we
jump to the we would jump to the chart
of the alerting metric populated with
that information so that's what kind of
the data and the situational awareness
to provide immediately upon arriving on
the page right so that's a typical
improvement we then kind of go further
down this is a duplicate of the metrics
of correlation so let's ignore that we
didn't go down and you see that hey
actually there's some similar incident
that happened similar to this alert
that's firing right now right and we
can't get a scene information that's
there we see cause tags that if you guys
can't can you guys read that I read it
out so there's cost tags on each cause
bug cause experiment and cause config
for three different calls did it happen
ignore the time this is cuz of me
preparing and said it all happened
yesterday
so this is unrealistic map that sense
but the actions were all different sorry
the actions were all the same so three
different causes but the axes are all
the same so that gave you two indicator
that for this kind of alert typically
you can solve the problem with a
failover all right so that's just upon
arriving on the page based on people
there the last time I don't have to go
find the post-mortem in some dock
somewhere or something some email and
figure it out I wasn't in her on call
but I have this history and knowledge
now baked into the tool at my fingertips
in the context of the Internet's
happening right now right so that's what
we're aiming for in this particular case
I could see that also the first two are
resolved and the other one is only
mitigated so maybe there's something
that you know still going on there
someone's still working on it but we
know that users and are no longer
impacted all right so it's just a
context and we also see the severity of
these examples as well right so for this
is the case I'm going to then start
investigating so I see that given a CPU
correlation this is the usual this is
not unusual because I have to write like
10 feet apart from my eyes
so so that that's as part of the kind of
the the key core data when you get
started in front of the data management
idea that's possible leveraging data
from different systems and also the
ability that when framework data out I
mentioned its idea of leveraging the
same framework for human curated data so
in this section here and investigation
updates right now it's very heavily text
the next thing we're gonna do here is
capture the actual ops data you want to
look at so instead of saying and noting
here that I looked at chart blah blah
blah metric and contained a blah blah
blah instead through stackdriver
dashboards you push the chart to IRM and
so this would be a screenshot presented
here of the chart use but not only that
we would capture the metadata of that
chart you looked at so in that previous
page not only then the other data for
you we would have show you the chart if
you always went to that chart but it's
kind of all that happen we will just
show you the chart alright so this is
the kind of way you can leverage data
for the actual internal response process
throughout kind of common production
cases I wanted to kind of go through the
overview can you guys see the better now
and then the picture before ok yeah ok
so let's say I was um I mean let me do
best practice best practices when you
start responding status severity I think
this is a minor I don't really know but
and this couple information here about
kind of the process elements and tools
of IRM so here's a case where we're
providing descriptions of severity to
help the consistency across kind of
different team members so everyone's
kind of trying to be as close as
possible to the same thing to describe
in the same situation let's say this was
a minor you can always update later so
don't be sorry about setting the
severity and update in the later is my
rule
I'll set comms to something in slack
something
and then let's say that during my
investigation I realized that actually
this is bigger than I thought this this
is actually quite substantial right this
is where you want to kind of like engage
that protocol of like oh I need any
coordination actually inserting
commander so right now I'm just a single
responder right it's just me Daenerys
but right now but let's say let's get
some more people involved right but if
what I want to do to kick that offer is
I want to escalate the incident so right
now this is a local incident in my my
local team right but its idea of
escalating I don't know if you guys you
guys heard of em gene that tool Co OMG
yeah so escalate an incident is kind of
a parallel of kind of getting to an OMG
level incident right where everyone in
the company can be go can go to one
place and see it and see what's going on
and with that process is this notion of
a preset so I mentioned the idea of
incidents are inevitable and you want to
plan for them so here's a case where
product catalog service is this a weird
thing but if it gets impacted it slows
down our shoppers right is this a known
thing so we prepared a preset just
repaired log hundred product catalog you
might do it in different dimensions but
for this example we're looking to do it
that way and so I'm going to apply that
preset so you see that the current
severity is minor and is rarely the
information in other fields but by
setting that alone and then hitting
escalate has got a couple clicks I
populated it with playbooks and the
links I identified subscriptions for VPS
and others that are typical stakeholders
I want to know what's going on when part
locks numbers goes down because
typically it's slow we know that its
impact is on quality because our users
will start thinking that hey this is
weird and that's a very lightweight way
to give kind of lessons learned through
that structure of tags so what's common
the most common ones are calls in action
you saw that on a different previous
page but here we actually the tag of
impact just to kind of quickly capture
that and we've added some templating to
the summary now so now we want to know
we want to capture a current status in
terms of is it user visible
or is it the greatest service but these
are just examples right you just want to
capture a template that everyone can do
so depend on your preset or your team
you might have particular information
that you want to know right like how
many users or which regions and so on so
this is easy way to kind of the
structure a summary like we mentioned to
be very plain English information and
then a key information we want to do
which at this stage is a plain text but
will be a structured information to be a
countdown what is the next update like
how old is the thing you just say to me
when would I get a update on what's
going on you know typically for
something that's major separators at the
major now it could be like 30 minutes or
20 minutes if it's huge you want anybody
in 15 minutes or something right so
that's one way to kind of quickly can
kind of turn up the gas and a response
and then I would go in and say okay
let's add some people to this row I want
to get into the commander my colleague
is here and then he could go on and then
add in a comms lead and so on but I
don't the primary responder at this
stage I would change to be obsolete and
continue to debug the process team would
come in and then start adding a comms
lead perhaps external communications
lead to make sure we're communicating
with the external world and start
slotting into those processes and roles
of the different elements okay so that
was kind of the heart of them I wanted
to give so one thing to kind of nail
home the point of what I arms vision is
right and that's really about I
mentioned the fewer shorter and smaller
outages and working towards that
leverage and data management right so
there's a lots of potential in this
approach but as it's a great foundation
in place and we plan to build on top of
that in IRM to help our users reduce
their medians and mitigation
and love your feedback and so in the in
the cloud next app please rate and
provide feedback be great next luck I do
it would be better all right so with
that I'm a I'm gonna I'm gonna call it
thank you guys so much for coming out
and hanging around
[Applause]
[Music]